ابدا معك مازن واخر التطورات
لديك نعم مريم من الواضح ان حزب الله حول
كل الخط والشريط الحدودي في عمق
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه الى منطقه امنيه
لا يمكن المستوطنين الاقتراب منها وباتت
هذه المستوطنات تحت نيرانه بشكل مباشر من
خلال الصواريخ التي يطلقها بشكل دائم وهو
ما ادى الى الحاق اضرار كبيره في البنيه
التحتيه لكل هذه المستوطنات بالاضافه الى
ايقاع اصابات في صفوف جنود قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هذا الامر بات واضحا ليس فقط
من خلال العمليات الاربعه التي نفذها
اليوم ولكن من خلال كل السياق الذي كنا
نرصده خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين على مستوى
العمليات التي حصلت منذ صباح اليوم
بالاضافه الى الاستهداف الصاروخي في منطقه
مزارع شبعه هنا في القطاع الاوسط والقطاع
الغربي كان ثمه استهدافات مباشره نفذ حزب
الله اخرها كان الاعلان عن الهجوم على
مستوطنه دفيف وتحديدا احد المواقع
العسكريه هناك ويتحدث عن قتلى وجرحه في
صفوف قوات الاحتلال بالاضافه الى استهداف
شومي وايضا ادميت الحديث الاسرائيلي عن
اصابه في ادميه مؤكده وفق التصريحات
الاسرائيليه ولكن ايضا هنالك انباء وفق
حزب الله عن اصابات اضافيه في شومير حيث
تم استهداف بالصواريخ غرفه رصد على مقربه
من ثكنه شميرا كل هذه المعطيات تتقاطع عند
التكتيك الذي بات يعتمده حزب الله والذي
حول كل الخط الحدو والمستوطنات في العمق
الاسرائيلي الى اهداف واضحه لعملياته
العسكريه بعدما تحولت هذه المستوطنات الى
الكونات بعدما اخذت الاداره الاسرائيليه
والاحتلال الاسرائيلي قرارا باخلاء 43
مستوطنه على طول الخط الحدودي واجلاء اكثر
من 120,000 مستوطن من تلك اللحظه بدا حزب
حزب الله يتعامل مع هذه المستوطنات بوصفها
سكونات عسكريه يمكنه توجيه صواريخه
باتجاهها ومن هنا تقرا البيانات الاخيره
التي كانت تصدر عن حزب الله والذي يتحدث
فيها عن استهدافات مباشره لمبان وتجمعات
عمرانيه سكنيه في عمق المستوطنات وذلك ردا
على كل الاستهدافات التي كنا نرصدها خلال
الفتره الاخيره والتي طالت عمق البلدات
اللبنانيه وهو ما ادى الى سقوط عدد من
شهداء خلال الايام الماضيه ليرتفع عدد
الشهداء الذين سقطوا في هذه العمليات
العسكريه التي تنفذها الطائرات والمسيرات
والمدفعيه الاسرائيليه الى اكثر من 25
شهيدا لبنانيا من المدنيين طيله فتره
القصف الاسرائيلي الذي يطال جنوب لبنان
اليوم ايضا كان هنالك غارات اسرائيليه في
اكثر من منطقه ولكن ابرزها وصلت ما بين
جبشيت وشوك في تلك المنطقه حصلت غاره
اسرائيليه وبالتالي اتساع دائره ورقعه
الاستهدافات جغرافيه من قبل قوت الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هو ما كان يستوجب من حزب الله
ردا في العمق الاسرائيلي يضاف الى ذلك ما
رصدناه بالامس من خلال اطلاق كتائب القسام
الصواريخ باتجاه مستوطنه ليمان التي كانت
اداره الاحتلال الاسرائيلي واداره
المستوطنات قد اعلنت قبل ثلاثه ايام عن
اخلائها وطلبت من المستوطنين مغادرتها
وبالتالي هذه الصور التي كنا نشاهدها قبل
قليل للمظاهرات للمستوطنين هو هي فعلا
ينظر اليها هنا بالنسبه لحزب الله وفي
لبنان بمثابه معامله بالمثل بمعنى ان ثمه
الان صوت قذيفه سقطت على مقربه من هذه
المنطقه لا يمكن تحديد المنطقه ولكن سنرصد
اي تداعيات محتمله ولكن قبل قليل ايضا كان
هنالك اطلاق لمجموعه من القنابل من
القنابل الحارقه في هذا الافق سنترك ك
تتابع كل هذه التطورات ل توافينا لاحقا
بتفاصيل ما تجري